لا اله الا
سند
السماوات
الذي يشفع الذي يعلم ما بين ايديهم وما
خلفهم لا يخل شيئا من علم ان بما شاء
مسيحيه والسماواتج
من النار اللهم اجرني
من النار اللهم اجن من النار
من نافع رزقا طيبا
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله والصلاه
والسلام على رسول الله وعلى اله واصحابه
اجمعين اما بعد كين ان الوجيز ان بوك فاست
ما زلنا في كتاب الوجيز في فقه السنه
والكتاب كتاب العزيز في ابواب الايام
التي
اي ندب الصيام
اليها الايام
التي
حث رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم على
صيامها
او على صيام بعضها
او هو صام بعضها صلى الله عليه وسلم
‏Continuing in the chapter regarding the
fasting
and the days which a person or which we
have been
highly encouraged to fast.
يقول المؤلف صيام اكثر المحرم
سنه
محرم محرم
ذحجه
ذ القعده ذو الحجه و محرم
بين جماده وشعبان وهي رجب
رجب
‏and
prop صلى الله عليه وسلم wasم
not
point wouldh fast the maority of m the
maority
so the month of m you find
صلى الله عليه وسلم
what year
and
two different way of seeing the so the
prop
محرم
ابو هريره
يقول المؤلف عن ابي هريره قال رسول الله
صلى الله عليه وسلم افضل الصيام بعد رمضان
شهر الله المحرم وافضل الصلاه بعد الفريضه
صلاه الليل فجعل صيام اكثر محرم او حتى لو
صام محرم
كله
فان الانسان يجوز له ان يفعل ذلك جعله
بمنزله قيام الليل لكن المؤلف من اين اخذ
صيام اكثر محرم
هو لان النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم قارن بين
قيام الليل
وصيام محرم
وكما قالت عائشه النبي صلى صلى الله عليه
وسلم لم يقم الليل كله قط ابدا ما قام
جميع الليل من بعد العشاء الى اي الى بزوغ
الفجر
يقوم في صلاته لا بد ان يكون له انقطاع
والنبي صلى الله عليه وسلم امره الله ان
يحيي اكثر الليل ولم يامره باحياء الليل
كله
and so ابو هريره the messenger of
saidous
after fast ofان
fast
المحرم
now this word
المحرم شهر
المحرم
understood
‏a
sachan
[Silence]
ذو القعده القعده ذو الحجه الحجه المحرمب
any time
is
to be
fasting
[Silence]
اللهران
صلى الله عليه
‏two things
compares them there is a relationship
that those two things share either in
likeness or in ruling or in virtue or in
whatever it is that the sentence is
speaking about in this sentence the
prophet
says the best of fasting
الله المحرم
صلاه الليل
عشاء
قيام الليل
صيام اكثر المحرمه
المحرمه يعني اي شهر من الاشهر المحرمه
‏maan
not
of monsor
where did get
the conclusion of fasting the majority
why not fasting the entirety
صلى الله عليه وسلم
فام
الليل
what those acts of worship share they
don't share likeness in the way that
they performed one is performed in the
day the other is performed in the
عائشه رضي الله عنها
صحيح مسلم
صلى الله عليه وسلم
ever
never in all
[Silence]
سوره المزمل الله
قم الليل قم الليل الا قليلا
نصفه او انقص منه قليلا او زد عليه
2د
‏of the no more not entiry of the
so one act of worship is done in the day
the other act of worship is done at
the act of worship that is done in the
day that is the most virtuous is fasting
and the act of worship that is done at
night that is most virtuous is praying
what time or what
[Silence]
صيام اكثر
المحرم
اكثر محرم
only محرم
ال هنا اللام تدل على انها صفه يعني اكثر
الشهر الموصوف
بالحرمه واللام هنا للجنس يعني جنس الشهر
المحرم فهذا يكون
هذه الاشهر الاربعه
ذقعده ذ الحجه محرم الرجب
بكره نفيع بن الحارث من صحيح البخاري
الله سبحانه وتعالى ساز ان عده الشهور عند
الله 12 شهرا في كتاب الله يوم خلق
السماوات والارض منها اربعه حرم
ذلك الدين القيم فلا تظلموا فيهن انفسكم
الله
[Silence]
ابو بكر
صلى الله عليه وسلم
ان حجت الوداع صحيح البخاري الا ان الزمان
قد استدار كهيئته يوم خلق الله السماوات
والارض
تقول منها اربعه حرم
او السنه 12 شهرا في كتاب الله يوم خلق
الله السماوات والارض منها اربعه حرم ذو
القعده وذو الحجه ومحرم ورجب مضر الذي بين
جماده وشعبان
‏And so there are sacred on these four
sacred on virtuous time to fast but you
don't fast the entir of the month
and all of these sacred months because
now you would make them just what
that's what intend the propet
was not to have
‏was never
يقول
اكثر شعبان
شعبان
رمضان
صلى الله عليه وسلم
شعبان
تقول عائشه
ما رايت رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
استكمل صيام شهر قط
الا شهر رمضان وما رايته في شهر اكثر منه
صياما في شعبان والحديث عند البخاري ومسلم
في صحيحما
عائشه
never seen الله صلى الله عليه
‏and never seen him fast more anyle
of
so now have and have
now
‏in chapter chapter
times which a person isited
from fasting
anything the 15th day ofan and we talk
about that and how we these two
narrations together and harmon them
insallah but for our in and purposes for
this chapter
tells
صلى الله عليه وسلم
[Silence]
صلاه at
night
and
شعبان
‏No, it's not specified.
Those are general ones in every month.
So the three days in the exact midle of
the month or Mondays and Thursdays or
every other day and the auor will
mention those towards the end of the
chapter. ‏However, these particular
narrations would fast random days
whatever was appropriate or whatever was
convenient for what he was doing if he
was traveling if he was not if he was
feeling up to it if he was not just like
there no specific time would always
stand for at
us would be at the last
but not always not
نعم الله اعلم وصلى الله وسلم على نبينا
محمد وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين جزاكم الله
خير
ياسر ابو الشعرات
دوم